[Music]
did I scare you high rejection it's your
girl Sally AKA Sally lomonaco AKA
salamander I am at Sally Lamonica on all
of my socials go subscribe to my channel
but before you do that subscribe to this
one today we are watching Insidious I
don't do while watching scary movies
alone I love a good scary movie but
alone not a fan I'm excited and not
excited I would like to sleep tonight
scary movies they're like a guilty
pleasure I enjoy the idea of watching
them and then when I am watching them I
tend to not finish them you can blame
Greg if I pick my pants anyway please
leave a like on this video if at any
point you Vibe with me and you're like
yes Queen same I remember when this
movie first came out I believe I was
like in high school and everyone was
like dude Insidious it's crazy and I was
like yeah I'm good I'm good so click
that notification Bell if you want to
check out more reactions from me Greg or
John all also please check out the
patreon it's patreon.com the real
rejects they are going to put to my full
reaction if you want to sit and have the
full experience with me like little
movie date you can't grab my hand if you
get scared you have to sync up with your
own copy though again patreon.com the
real rejects let's just do it rip off
the payday salary also thanks to prepper
for editing together these highlights
three two one
oh
[Music]
[Music]
girl no
stop stop stop oh my God that was not
necessary just saying
Why do ghosts like moving pictures it's
so annoying
uh
I hate dolls I can't I can't look at it
this is just the freaking opening
credits
um
hey sweetie oh she's matching show me a
picture where Dad was a little kid and I
wish I could but I don't think we have
any he's really hopeless at keeping
photos
every time I think I've pulled you out
I crawl back in
he's like Chris Pratt with more hair
don't like that
I've been like oh it's just the kids
right
the kids are reading
[Music]
foreign
sounds like the toilet
why would you put an infant on like the
second floor
um
scary
I can't do this
it's just a ladder
it's always the heater why is it always
the heater oh it's just the heater
making the noise
all right
nope
why would you go up there why would you
do it what is the re why it just closed
the door crazy kid
asking for it go downstairs I don't want
to be up here
okay
ow
en
what happened did you fall did you fall
off the ladder how did you fall down
yeah
what were you doing
okay
yeah he may be a superhero buddy but
you're not invincible
you got to be careful all right okay
um
I think I have a couple of good songs I
mean not all of them but I think
[Music]
I love all your stuff shut up you do not
stop it
cute
I don't know what that was
can you go wake up dogs and Josh
oh no
hey sleepy pads you better get out of
that bed your mother's gonna kill us
both
did he get a concussion Dalton don't
don't
Dalton
there's no brain damage that we've
detected
there's gotta be something
I'm sorry
just stay here we'll conduct some
further testing it's only been a couple
of days it could take a little longer
it's like every parent's nightmare
oh
girl go get your baby
go get your
baby
[Music]
I want it I got it I want it I get it
[Music]
[Music]
stop looking at things oh my God I'm
scared mom
me too boy
I'm scared of what
don't do
can I change rooms
why would you want to change rooms
I don't like when he walks around at
night
listen
um
back to the hospital with you
it's probably just interference those
things are always picking up somebody
else's I don't know it sounded so clear
it scared the hell out of me and I was
at the piano and you could hear it on
the Monitor and I turned
I would have called my husband at work
and be like [ __ ] get home right now
oh my God I hated that I hate these
headphones now
stop
hello
oh my God you're crying okay I hate you
oh my God [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[Music]
there's nobody here I saw someone bring
the crab in your room
Jesus
[Music]
stop there can't be another jump scare
this early [ __ ]
oh my God call the cops
stop
stop
get in an Airbnb or something
[Music]
unnecessary
see you tomorrow
wait is that the saw guy
on the chalkboard is that jigsaw on the
chalkboard it is
hey honey it's me
um Dave just told me I've got to uh I
gotta I'm gonna have to stay late
tonight to uh I gotta grade some tests
no you need to get home to your wife no
you need to get home to your wife
[Music]
hmm
how did the nurse not
ice that
oh
no
bye moving honey we're going we're going
I'm scared of this house it's like a
sickness ever since we've moved and
everything's just
gone wrong you think our house is
haunted I don't think it I know at the
time yes
fine deal with this
oh he's on my couch I don't care if I'm
mad at you you're sleeping in the bed
with me because I'm not gonna get
murdered
same
no
oh yeah
oh Jesus
good job
no that's not your husband idiot
maybe if he slept in the bed with hmm
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh that means the Slytherin
[Music]
interesting so they do move
but like
that like never happens
until the end
I can't believe you got Josh to hold
still for a photo not me or anybody
knows what you're going through right
now
whatever you have to do to get through
it do it
and you don't have to apologize for
anything
she's very intense
[Music]
oh my God
was that a child
foreign
came from
um
oh no
child no
stop laughing
stop it
I'm good
dolphin
that's not Dalton you idiot
[Music]
gotta be crying too
it's a lot of money to get a third house
last night I
went into Dalton's room there was
something in there with it
it was standing there in the corner
no
I
asked it who are you and it said
The Visitor
I said what do you want
stop it
said Dalton
still hear that voice
oh Jesus
[ __ ]
Greg
piss myself
oh my God
I know someone who can help
if you're willing to ask
why are you so skeptical
excuse you
[Music]
where is Elise she sent us ahead to do
something
help sweet out the nut jobs
oh great here comes another drink
I really don't like this
I'm Josh I knew that
I've grown since I last saw you
last saw me
your mother and I have been friends a
long time
so this thing happened to him as a kid
but
that was the flashback
what is it
stop I don't want to see it I just want
to see the drawing
[Music]
stop stop how do I see it I said I don't
see it
it's your son
I don't understand
have you ever heard of astral projection
um
he has you see these are people with the
ability to leave their physical body
and to travel to different places in
astral form
and it's that very lack of fear that has
led him to travel too far
and to become lost in a place that I
call the further is a Dark Realm filled
with the tortured Souls of the Dead
a place not meant for the living
there are entities that know this
because they can smell it
that's why they're gathered around them
they're all trying to get inside of his
physical body simply because they
they crave life
I'm gonna head out I can't have somebody
coming into our home and telling us that
the reason our son is in a coma is
because his soul is floated off
somewhere in another dimension we're
gonna bring her all the way here and not
even consider what she's saying I did
this to make sure you could feel at ease
don't Gaslight her
not to believe anybody you don't believe
me
[Music]
but this
this is dangerous you guys lighting your
gaslighting you know it's true
[Music]
you're telling me they move houses and
hung these up on the wall come on
[Music]
okay
[Music]
look scary
can you hear us
answer us
where are you
[Music]
I don't understand
follow my voice Dalton
why aren't you talking anymore
if they hear me they'll hurt me
who will hurt you
who will hurt you Dalton
I don't like it helps
is she good bro
is she possessed now
[Music]
what
foreign
oh no
turn down the lights
[Music]
three cameras
Around the Clock
we got nothing
I mean it got nothing that was insane
I was like holy no worries oh my gosh
friend
my friend
my friend
bro
no Mom what are you doing here
I asked your mother to come over I
called her immediately after the session
why there's something we must talk about
my husband was possessed at what point
hmm
it's no accident that your son is a
gifted Traveler
the ability was handed down to him
by his father
at first I thought it was a camera
problem
uh no
finally I was so frightened I found
Elise
everywhere
new lion you're still afraid to have
your picture taken aren't you
one that can bring them back
and with what we saw tonight I would say
he doesn't have much time left to wait
for you
a sound man
by not advancing himself
stays the further ahead of himself
I have no idea what I'm doing
hahaha
let my voice
in a steady stride
into the further
oh so scary
the younger version of him that's so
creepy
foreign
[Music]
foreign
don't mess with these weirdos
again
tell me where my son is
please
what
uh-uh
um
you're ugly
I think Dalton annoy the show just be
like Dalton Dalton Dalton Dalton
Blue's Clues Blue's Clues you know what
to do
foreign
ER than they are Josh you are the one
alive get away from me
bye
baby Dalton Daddy
oh God
oh my God
daddy look I'm free okay okay okay face
me buddy face me come here
what
[Music]
ah cats the amazing girl
he found your son
no not the lights stop stop stop stop
[Music]
Daddy Let's
Josh follow my voice
no
better not be the woman
what
the hell Stephen Lorraine go check on
Dalton what go check on Dalton what go
check out Dalton now how many times did
she have to say it
got two
crossing over
no they're not no no no no no no no no
[Music]
no
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
please
[Music]
let him go
you
oh no
[Music]
um
[Music]
what do you want from me
what do you want from me yeah [ __ ]
figure it out you can get away from me
get the hell away from me
get away from me it's not funny stop
laugh why is everyone laughing
get the hell away from me
[Music]
foreign
wake up okay good
[Music]
poor baby
[Music]
[Music]
she's like bruh
[Music]
I got some amazing shots
[Laughter]
really hungry aren't you
and I'm tired too
because you're tired
I wouldn't go to sleep
I guess I don't need these anymore
what
nothing
I'm gonna get rid of these
um
why did you do that
why would you do that to me when you
know how I feel about that why
the science is it it's not him is it
nice
[Music]
what
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
I'm right here
that ending it gave me chills
okay that was good that was good that
was good I'm not gonna lie I'm not gonna
lie that was pretty good listen I love
me a good twist and at first I was like
this is like a homework ending like how
cute but I wasn't like mad about it
because I was happy to not be scared
anymore but whoa I like that ending that
was a good ending I can see why people
said this was a really good movie it
keeps you on your toes it was a
simplistic plot yet visually it was
really intricate the acting was really
good too the older woman she killed it
Elise was her name in the movie so
compelling she was awesome Dalton was
really good I mean the husband Chris
Pratt like
times 10 you know what I mean it was
scary but it was still gratifying if
that makes sense you know some movies
are just scary to be scary and you don't
feel like you walked away like connected
to any of the characters or like caring
that much you're just like what but like
I really cared you know
little dolled in this movie seems iconic
in a way that I remember when it came
out everyone was talking about it and I
feel like for a horror movie to do that
it's kind of rare especially with all
the CGI we have and everything I think
the last horror movie that really made
me feel some type of way was hereditary
and for some reason I agreed to see that
in theaters I don't know why and yeah
that was it was disturbing to say the
least so I feel like in terms of iconic
you know horror movies this definitely
is in that uh category I feel like
because it was just such a talked about
subject when I was in high school and
still now you know like people refer to
it all the time like that red guy in
Insidious
I get it that was a good movie because
like I would have been fine with the
ending not having that twist I would
have been like still that was like a
movie but like that twist though
but now I feel so bad for him like go
get your husband like oh my God it's
done it was giving stranger things a
little bit but I think this came out
before stranger things but it's kind of
an interesting like similar concept
except obviously the physical body was
still there well technically I mean 11
can like technically actual product in a
way interesting I felt validated
watching this movie because I did live
in a haunted house at one point and
there were a few things that the wife
was feeling and going through that like
I went through and people will try to
make you feel crazy and they'll try to
Gaslight you but like trust your gut
trust your instinct I'm curious okay so
now I remember watching it being like
how would they do a sequel you know if
they got Dalton if everything's fine and
now I really want to see the second one
I was sitting here like in the middle
hating on it I was like I'm not gonna
watch the rest of these but like should
I it scared me it scared me good it
scared me good A lot of the shots were
really interesting obviously the first
shot with a lamp and then everything you
know turning up I down and I joked about
the upside down technically it's like a
very similar concept so the visuals were
very good and if that red man bro
I don't like him okay I don't think
anyone should like him Darth Maul
looking ass
it's funny I say that but I don't really
like remember those Star Wars movies and
I don't remember Darth Maul I've just
seen him on like everything Star Wars
anyway the coloring in this movie is
really interesting for most of the movie
it's very Bleak not much color not much
saturation obviously with some Reds they
pop out but I found it interesting the
saturation like the color was super low
kind of this like grayish green color
and then when he is in the further uh
the colors are way more saturated way
brighter they've got the bright red the
bright teal
um stuff like that was really cool to
see in the further and it kind of
definitely made you feel like you were
in a different world
um so that was a really interesting
choice and I I enjoyed that I don't like
the people that were just standing there
staring I don't like them I think that
they shouldn't have been there just for
my sanity it was creepy I didn't get it
I like it that room I've had like a
nightmare similar to obviously like that
room where people are just around you
and they're
it brought back flashbacks you know you
have some nightmares that just stick
with you for your whole life that that's
similar I've had one of those also
grabbing of the ankles and yanking add
one of those don't forget that it's
scary because I feel like some people
can relate to like having night terrors
or sleep paralysis nightmares and this
reminded me a lot of that only like
times 10 this is like sleep paralysis
turned up to 11 not a fan not a fan of
that I get it now like I get why
everyone's like oh my God it's so scary
and it's so good also I should mention I
totally forgot to mention this I
remember I had seen memes from this
movie it was the the red guy behind
Chris Pratt 2.0 uh times 10. so I'd seen
that photo of that red guy and I
remember in high school people were like
oh this is so scary like of this dude
now I know where that's from and also
the Tip Toe Through the Tulips F that
song I don't like it like I know that
song has existed before listening to me
but I know that this these kind of what
made it popular for like the horror
genre I think anyways if you guys want
me to react to any more horror films
please leave a comment below if you want
me to react to the other Insidious
movies let me know because like now I'm
invested I don't know if I can be
scarier than that but my God please give
this video a like if you enjoyed my
reaction at all give it a thumbs up
share it if you think it's funny like
send it to someone again subscribe it's
free trick or treat subscribe it's a
treat so I'm gonna check uh it's night
time now and I should go to bed and I'm
gonna say a long prayer tonight
it made me feel some type of way thanks
again for watching please subscribe to
my channel I put up a new Vlog for
Halloween it's gonna be up when this
video is gonna be up and it's super fun
I actually get murdered in a Texas
Chainsaw fashion and I vlogged uh my
experience on set so it's super fun so I
was also in a horror movie but honestly
this seemed creepy I feel like as an
actor if I was filming this I don't
think I'd have to act that much either
in this because like all those people
standing there when he was just with the
lamp and then like getting her ankles
yanked and like even as an actor I feel
like this would be scary to do because I
didn't see a lot of CGI I saw a lot of
people in like practical effects which
is awesome and like really refreshing to
see because they easily could have done
CGI with all this but I feel like I
could tell there were some shots with it
obviously but like I definitely could
see that they use real people for being
ghosts and everything that being said
this is a classic and I see it I get it
I get the hype so anyway have a great
and safe Halloween please stay safe out
there check your candy don't drink and
drive and have some fun and with that
being said I will see you next time
[Music]